torrent represents the most important
feature of eldon ring the open world he
is our gateway to explore the vast world
through but unfortunately he falls flat
from a gameplay perspective
everyone mad luigi here in this video i
want to take a slightly different style
than many of my previous videos because
i want to talk about some aspects of
elden ring beyond just the lore i want
to talk about the gameplay around
torrent and my issues with it
if you saw my torrent lore video you
will have some idea what i mean as a
character torrent has some backstory and
motivational development but he seems
not fully realized for what he is our
constant companion who is with us
throughout the game and this feeling of
incompleteness only grows when we
consider the core experience of the game
which is the gameplay when you start the
game you are quickly given torrent to
assist in your open world exploration he
makes for a companion who is always with
you and opens up a new way to quickly
traverse the world whether that be
through galloping around or jumping up
onto things with your double jump and he
also allows for mounted combat which
often gives you an edge over foot
soldiers grounded enemies and even
flying enemies but as you progress
through the game leveling up increasing
your stats and gaining new abilities
torrance stays almost exactly the same
throughout the entire game
your experience at level 1 on torrent is
going to be nearly identical to your
experience at level 100 the only
ostensible changes are maybe a health
increase and the fact that leveling
dexterity is supposed to make it harder
to get knocked off of torrent but it
very much didn't feel this way in my
playthrough and when i went to test it i
couldn't find any evidence to support
either of these ideas the health on
torrent seems unchanged by whether or
not i'm on a late game level 100 plus
character or on a brand new level 10
character and the ability to be knocked
off torrent seems the same regardless of
level i tested on a character with
literally level 1 decks and a character
with max 99 decks and it took the same
number of enemy attacks to unseat me
from torrent a basic limb grave enemy
with a torch took me off torrent in five
hits in both cases and a kite and
sellsword took me off torn on both
characters and three to four swings of
his sort
maybe something in these tests missed
how torn's poise is supposed to work but
in my time with the game it has felt
like there isn't really any change to
torrent despite how much i progressed my
character i never felt like i could take
more hits from even basic early game
enemies before torrent would disappear
and i'd be locked into a falling
animation
and this lack of progression is my core
issue with torrent especially because
there are so so so many ways to make
torrent feel like part of our journey of
progression ways which would fit because
torrent is supposed to be somewhat of a
character
the first potential changes are obvious
and connected with what we just
discussed make tangible upgrades to
torrance health stamina and poi is
possible these can either scale directly
with the player like how it is supposed
to do with decks or be tied to items or
armor found throughout the world giving
players the opportunity to increase
tauren's health and stamina can make it
feel like he is growing to meet new
challenges just like us the player
increasing poise and the ability to
withstand more hits would help to show
progression and give a feeling to the
player of really having grown and being
stronger when returning to earlier areas
a similar upgrade that would help
torrent be more fun would be the
possibility of increasing his speed
maybe i'm a bit biased because i always
love speed increases in games like how
crackdown 2's agility orbs are some of
my favorite experiences in gaming but
some speed upgrades for torrent
throughout the game could work well to
make traversing the large sections of
the map more enjoyable these could be
more restrictive than the other upgrades
as speed is a pretty sensitive thing to
the rhythm of fromsoft games and they
could even be disabled for the few boss
fights that allow torrent in them but
getting to return to lyrnia or caled as
a late game character and gallop through
them at a couple tiers of faster speed
would be a great feeling
and as torrent is a spectral steed these
could be accompanied by some added
spirit effects to denote the higher
speeds maybe they could be tiers of
speed that can be unlocked and activated
for a certain maybe limited amount of
time so you're not always zooming around
at 200 speed but you still get to
traverse the large open world a bit
faster and slotting these upgrades
towards the late game would allow the
balance present in most of the game to
stay the same for your first playthrough
and an associated quality of life change
would be to make the galloping a bit
more streamlined so the player doesn't
have to repeatedly spam the run button
to make torrent maintain full speed and
in line with this kind of spirit speed
upgrade i think another really obvious
area for more progression for torrent
can be found in the ancestral spirits
if you saw my lore video you might be
able to guess it but i think allowing
torrent to unlock a third jump like the
regal ancestor has would be a classic
video game upgrade if we also want to
let torrent into these fights which
would fit since they have such big
arenas and given the lore connection
between tauren and the spirits we could
have tauren unlock the third jump after
defeating one of them and then use it
during the fight with the second one
which would be very thematic or just
unlocking it after the second one works
too and it would also be cool to be able
to attack when torrent makes his second
jump or in this case even his third
now this is going to be one of the
biggest reaches of a change despite how
straightforward it seems because a third
jump would let the player access more
things vertically so the world would
have had to been designed with that in
mind because that would be a lot of work
this is less plausible as a change that
could be implemented now it would have
had to be considered when the game world
was being created but it still seems
like something that could have fit in
really well making it a mid to late game
unlock that lets us access new heights
and areas
and a note on bosses too it would have
been great to see torrent especially a
torrent with more upgrades in more boss
fights ranala has a very open second
phase to allow for torrent just make her
float around a bit more spoiler warning
and of course the elden beast fight
would have been a fantastic opportunity
for torrance inclusion both thematically
and gameplay-wise he is our constant
companion around since the start of the
game so having him there at the end of
the game would be great and him being
around for the gameplay would limit the
time spent chasing the elden beast and
make for a very cinematic final fight
which is obviously what from software is
going for in theme
to cap off the ability discussion we
can't use ashes of war while on torrent
so why not allow us to unlock combat
abilities to be used instead a great
candidate would be the body slam attack
that many of the horse-based bosses use
against us like the knight's cavalry and
the tree sentinels body slams stomps or
other combat options would give more
variety to mounted gameplay and allow
for some cool new unlocks from horse
bosses how cool would it be to defeat a
knight's cavalry and instead of getting
a random ash of war you get one of their
horse's attacks
and we will have truly come full circle
with the next suggestion but it needs to
be said
horse armor in a similar way to player
armor horse armor could provide
aesthetic variety to torrent signify and
reward player exploration and even allow
players to modify torrent to their given
playstyle
heavy armor could make torrents slow but
sturdier able to withstand more attacks
before disappearing light armor can make
torrent lighter and more stamina
friendly while sacrificing defense and
poise we've come a long way since the
original horse armor dlc fiasco but i
think this would be a worthwhile change
that could fit with the themes of the
game in progression rpg playstyle
variants and exploration
all of these upgrades and abilities and
armor possibilities would also really
help with one of the other main issues i
have with the game the loot because the
open world of eldon ring is so big it
can sometimes feel less worthwhile to
explore when a lot of the loot you find
ends up being extremely class dependent
or unusable to your playstyle or
roleplay this is something joseph
anderson mentioned in his critique video
that resonated with me these torn
upgrades would give a chance to include
more universal loot in a lot of the
areas of the game so players could still
find their desired spells and other
items but they'd also be unlocking more
universal upgrades more people would
have more reason and reward to do more
exploration it would also make the
repetitive caves and catacombs a little
bit more bearable if you were more
confident that they would surely give
you something that would benefit your
playthrough and this would carry over to
subsequent playthroughs too making them
more enticing to do more exploration
there are more possibilities i could
discuss like the ability to interact
with torrent outside of mounted gameplay
such as to pet him or to have some form
of character development with him as his
lore suggests should be there to some
degree there are small things like the
annoying message asking if you want to
revive him every time he dies or how the
player dying doesn't reset torrent's
health but i think enough examples have
been given to illustrate the point oh
except for one last one which would be
really easy to implement more
consumables with all the ingredients and
crafting in the game or that the game
wants us to do we could be able to make
different berry mixtures or flavored
raisins that affect torrent either
making him faster granting him certain
abilities offering buffs or any other
kind of possible effect this would also
be more feasible to implement in an
update or offer in dlc
torrent is a defining feature of nunes
and eldon ring he is essentially the
conduit of the open world and next to
nothing is done with him he gets
essentially no progression in gameplay
or in lore character or story he could
have been one more grand avenue for
fromsoft to drive home the benefits of
exploration and increase the fun of open
world traversal
instead he is utterly static and doesn't
contribute anything more to the game in
the middle or end than he does the
moment you receive him in a game that is
so clearly focused on exploration and
rpg progression he stands out as a
lacking area which doesn't flow with so
many of eldon rings core themes
i think torrent is a great addition but
because he could have been so much more
i think he clearly stands as one of the
game's biggest letdowns and missed
opportunities not as something
necessarily bad but as something that
could have made this already wonderful
game even that much better
and that is the summary of my feelings
on torrent as a gameplay mechanic i hope
you enjoyed the video even if you're
someone who comes to my channel for lore
torrent is a good case where the lore
and gameplay share similar themes of
comment and how they both could have
been expanded so i thought this was a
good place to bridge into a gameplay
discussion if you want more elder ring
videos make sure you subscribe since
i'll be making more lore videos and more
videos like this where i discuss
features of the game beyond just the
lore i think i even want to do a full
game critique soon so this is like stage
1 of that well thank you all for
watching and i'll see you in the next
video bye